I want to start off by saying thank you
so much for coming into the studio today
before we get started the only reason I
get to do this today Collider being here
at TIFF is because of the house of
Aurora where we're partnering up with
them and so I want to give a huge thank
you to house of Aurora or also have cool
jackets right yeah I was gonna say
actually they have there supposed to be
some gift bags actually and I don't know
right yeah they've already done so much
for us already right but I will work on
that because I do think there's supposed
to be some you know but anyway so
they're being very kind so I'm starting
with that I really dug your movie a lot
awesome
so much in the thing I had the advantage
of watch I thank you I really I one of
the things though that I had the
advantage of is I didn't know anything
going in so I'm watching it and as
everything's happening I have no idea of
the twists and turns so I don't want to
reveal too much about this because
that's half the fun of the of the film
so how do you want to sort of tell
people about it and without I guess
saying too much yeah well we love that
sense of mystery and we've been
describing the movie as a story about a
7 year old girl named Chloe who's being
trapped in this abandoned dilapidated
house by her paranoid father played by
Emile Hirsch and he's telling her don't
go outside because if you go outside
you'll kill us both look outside yeah
and eventually she gets up the courage
to go outside and escape and she
realizes her father was right and that's
kind of the the first tease you know
that's only the first 15 minutes of the
movie I see lots of stuff happens from
there but that's kind of the the you
know a starting point yet the the
biggest issue of course is like how do
you talk about like your characters how
do you because like and also even a
trailer like you have to tell people
what the movie is about but it's like
it's one of those films where the less
you know the better but it's you know
you know what I mean absolutely man good
luck
yes well that's what we love about films
it's so rare these days everything gets
so exposed and we we just wanted to make
something that is a mystery that's
really satisfying as it as it unravels
and kind of reveals a little piece by
piece and most of that through the
perspective of Lexi's character because
we wanted to tell a movie through the
perspective of a child who's as she's
learning things so is the audience and
so that was kind of the design from the
very beginning we're gonna get to you in
a second but how are you describing your
characters in the movie without saying
so much well your your your interview
number one so let's take a stab at it
let's see how it goes
well I play Lexi's mom in the movie and
there's a lot of question marks around
the disappearance of my character and
it's kind of one of the main questions
in the movie and becomes kind of a
driving force for her character to
figure out what happened to me nailed it
[Laughter]
my character is basically the leader of
a military faction that goes to gather
freaks and that that's one of the things
that this character goes around to do
and that's all I'm saying
so Lexi let's jump in to talk a little
bit about your anchoring this movie this
is you know if we don't believe in your
character and what she's going through
emotionally the film doesn't work so
talk a little bit about landing this
role and what it was like making this
movie well the process was movie and I
thought it was really awesome so when I
when I knew that I got the part I was
very excited and I went to Vancouver
yeah right we'll talk a little bit about
what it's like on set for you I'm
working like every day because I'm sure
you're not used to spending you know
what are the working hours in Canada is
it eight hours a day for kids six for
the legally-binding amount is we used
every second
and and and it was very intense right
being doing this role there was some
more like in tensing's and others
definitely like there were some scenes
that I had like scream and like there
were and there were some scenes that I
got to eat ice cream so I was gonna say
and those are the ones you circled in
the script and said fun day right I
remember there was one day where she had
ice cream in her hand all day long and
we wanted it to like melt and stuff and
and so we kept saying don't eat this one
Lexi and she yeah one of the things is
you guys one of the things that
commended this film about is that you
guys clearly had a limited budget but
you did the most with what you had and
one of the secrets is you limited
locations and you know but so talk a
little about the challenges of trying to
pull this off on a limited budget and
also because again no spoilers but you
have also VFX you know there are some
key scenes in this movie yeah I mean
when Adam and I came up with the idea
for this film we're actually really
inspired by a speech that Mark Duplass
gave at Austin where he kind of
encouraged filmmakers to use what they
had whatever you have go make a movie
about that and so we started with an
idea that was very simple so that no
matter what we could make this movie and
yeah it only has a few elements but we
really wanted to make sure it was
grounded in the characters and the story
so that you weren't too restricted by
the limited locations I mean it goes out
into the real world it's not all stuck
in one house or all stuck in one thing
like a lot of thrillers are it
definitely grows and grows and grows as
the movie goes and we had a lot of
visual effects as well but that's just
to kind of open up the movie as it goes
along well yeah we we started in a house
but we as we were writing we kind of
felt like wow it really wants to go
outside you know it really wants to get
out of this house and go to new places
and and so we just went there and and we
knew that that would impact the budget
and be something that was a challenge
for a small film like ours but
we tried not to inor Ganic li you know
trap it in one place for too long we
wanted to kind of go where where the
story and where the characters family
owns a restaurant so we're like well
maybe she goes to a restaurant well well
that was the Duplass inspiration you
know he was talking about oh we had a
puffy chair in a van so we made a movie
about that and originally you know we
started writing it when my son was four
or five years old we're like okay it's
about a kid in a house and that's where
we started because worse comes to worst
we just make it with my son and us in it
and then as we wrote the script and it
got out there you know more and more
awesome people kind of came on board and
made it what it is
you a bunch of other questions but you
guys also have to share where you two
met because it's pretty crazy so if you
could share that story great good story
we met on a reality television show
called on the lot America's Next Top
Model i won you came in second
no actually was the opposite we were on
on the lot which was a reality show sort
of like American Idol but for filmmakers
run by Steven Spielberg I'll make sure
he's a little up-and-comer he's gonna do
great and we made films every week and
we were competitors set against each
other but very quickly we just started
collaborating and and made movies
together as when we were on that show
and we became incredibly close friends
and we've now started collaborating as
co directors yeah over the years we
worked separately but we kind of kept
coming back together and when we started
thinking about like what what's the
personal kind of passion project we want
to make we just totally jelled on it and
came up with this I remember I remember
watching on the lot and I was going oh I
hope Zack beats that guy and then
they're doing a movie together like hey
for the record he came in third and I
came in what is it like for the actors
what is it like working for two
directors is it one of them has like is
it did you ever have a scene where one
of them gave you a note and then like
three seconds later another one comes
over and says of that and I was actually
really surprised by how cohesive they
were in their vision and I assumed going
into it that you know oh maybe Adam will
be the one that I asked about character
stuff and Zach's the one that I asked
about know it was very cool to to see
them work together and how how fluid
they were they they were in and out of
scenes and basically their direction was
right on point but it was it's how they
brought it to us and wasn't confusing at
all it was it was really great to work
with except that one time when I asked I
was like so I'm I'm I'm Chloe's mom and
then I was like no no you're her sister
and I was just like but that oh that
changed you know that day was a really
hard day what was it like for you it was
cool having two directors because it's
like one of them is behind the camera
and one of them is like on set telling
you your directions so it was like
having one director but everywhere it's
like it's like having because they're
there a lot of like I think cuz they're
both very good filmmakers obviously and
yeah it was I think it was it was really
cool for me having two directors for
each of you I was like ask about
memorable moments from filming is there
a day or two that you will always
remember from the shoot yeah actually my
birthday was on set
lexy turn to 8 while we were filming it
was extra ice cream exactly
well Mitch one of the producers I think
he got me like an ice cream truck I got
to like serve ice cream to people which
is really cool and I got a cake it was a
really fun day on set that was my
birthday and that was the day that she
was riding around in a truck with Bruce
Dern screaming at each other all day
long
that was their eighth birthday it was
fun though it was really fun I was a
really good fun birthday so that was a
day that always remember on set I
remember every single day because I was
either sweating because we were filming
in the Attic of this really old house
with no air conditioning honestly so I
remember those days very well or we were
filming in a mining tunnel with no light
and dripping water everywhere and I was
very cold so it was one extreme or the
other they were all very memorable
I remember your first day amande you
basically came to set and we're like
welcome here
let's drench you in blood and strap you
to this when I my first day on set and
you know Bruce Dern was on set I'm like
oh my god legendary Bruce Dern and then
I sit with him in the green room and one
of the second sentence second sense out
of his mouth was like I'm the only guy
to kill John Wayne in a movie and I'm
like keep talking yeah and they were
hearing his stories is pretty remarkable
that was a great great person you paid
to be exact exactly keep the money
yeah I'll say one of the highlights for
me was there's actually a key scene
between a meal and Bruce where they kind
of go at each other and it only lasts
for maybe a minute in the movie but we
just let them go and they went at each
other for like 20 minutes and we just
like and everyone we were you there's a
lot of crew in the house also are off
our production offices were in the house
as well and all the people just started
coming down
witness like these two amazing actors
just and like just being like I'm
witnessing something right now and it
was so hard to kind of edit that down to
what it is in the movie but to see both
of them just basically doing the script
and their own stuff and just screaming
at each other and then they would go
back to the beginning the scene they
just kind of kept they were just in this
tirade together and it was amazing to
see we we did a lot of improv and it was
always exciting to see the new things
that people added to the script to
really bring it to life and that scene
in particular was one as soon as Bruce
was cast he's like alright who's playing
this other role because that guy better
dance
he better be able to dance that was that
was his favorite scene you know with
everyone coming into the studio we've
been playing something called get to
know your Tiff's a tenday these are some
harmless questions I promise but it's
it's really we'll find out in five
minutes
what TV for for the actors what TV show
would you love to guest spot on and for
the writer directors what TV show would
you love to guest write and direct I
think for me it would be mash but not
the German version because I can't speak
German so but I'll do the English
version I'd say I heard Spielberg's
doing amazing stories again and with
with Apple and we're available my
sisters show so I probably want to get
star on that it's new it's called Sydney
to the max so I would probably want to
get star on that challenge I think you
have a family connection we can maybe
make that happen it's possible actually
before we continue the game I have to do
a follow up with you guys didn't you
just direct or are directing something
for them yeah we just wrapped on Kim
Possible live-action version of the the
classic cartoon so yeah which was a huge
amazing privilege it's such a great
source material we're
super fans of the show and we got to
work with the original creators and a
lot of the original talent you know we
had the original Kim Possible was did a
cameo on the movie and we had Patton
Oswald come and redo a character that he
played in the in the movie and it was
just such a fun world super excited for
the world for everybody to see it and
that's going to be on the streaming so
sometime next year do you have a
favorite sci-fi or fantasy film first
Blade Runner Back to the Future
number one probably Jurassic Park is in
there as well yeah Sesame Street you are
good at this game
is there anything that you guys collect
[Music]
I collect seashells when I go to the
beach I collect old cameras I also
collect old cameras but I usually steal
a prop from every show that we work on
so I have in my house is all the
different props from our movies tears
from the children I work with oh you got
a lot in this movie what's really funny
is the next question is and we got a rap
really soon
is do you own any movie or TV show props
oh you wouldn't have hypothetically
borrowed anything from the set of freaks
well I did work on a movie called The
Little Mermaid with Shirley MacLaine and
they and there's a mermaid and obviously
and they gave me like a bracelet of the
mermaid's tail
Wow and they also gave me like a doll
that was on the set so that was really
nice too so you do have some props yeah
I do I have the only copy of the mr.
snow cone pop-up book from freaks which
I like a lot as I said I already have a
lot of props for my own movies but my
one sort of related cherished possession
is an autograph from Carrie Fisher that
she wrote cuz she was a judge on on the
lot and I have an autograph of hers that
says to my favorite director no one's
giving me bracelets from mermaid tails I
stole I shouldn't say stole you borrowed
you're gonna give it back right yeah I
did war for the Planet of the Apes and
we have these standards and I was gonna
take both of mine but I only took one
cuz I couldn't find the other one and
then I kind of hid it in my jacket like
okay I just did my house just it's like
an arm now he plays a one-legged a
one-legged I don't have you have a phone
but what's your background photo on your
phone okay mine's Amanda not creepy at
all my adorable dog she's got a
permanent underbite and one wild eye
he's so cute
his name is Daryl and he's not up for
sale mines me and my girlfriend kissing
at sunset I love that it's pretty good
my two boys I've
- son so I used my mom's phone a lot but
hers is like a purple and blue like like
it's purple and blue and when you touch
like hold down on it it moves around you
don't have your own phone yet Lexi
that's good have you asked for one what
movie have you what wait and last two
things what TV show have you watched all
the way through more than once
mine's the British office Real
Housewives of any zip code mine's
Firefly wash it three times
dim fronts I think I've watched a show
called castle definitely more than once
episodes Oh one with a Nathan Fillion
yeah sorry buddy what movie have you
watched more than ten times Little
Mermaid truly I mean he was listening to
Hamilton on the car ride over here so I
believe that why would
that's a don't judge me no it's
fantastic
that was the beginning of the
Renaissance of Disney Animation there
you go yeah mrs. Doubtfire and that's
not a joke that's Goonies Back to the
Future Jurassic Park the matrix the Pulp
Fiction and I've watched the extended
edition Lord of the Rings all the way
through in one day three times
you have me beat on that I think I've
done it twice inside those classics of
our childhood one movie I keep coming
back to again and again is Brazil but I
just always find something new and to
appreciate
I watched frozen a billion yeah I am NOT
surprised in the least
so you're basically you're counting the
days to the sequel yes you know you know
they're making a sequel did you know
that you know they really are they're
making it as we speak it's coming out I
think next year melted right totally I'm
letting you know there's a new one and
it's a sequel and it comes out next year
exactly on that note I have to say thank
you thank you guys so much for coming in
and answering some of my fun questions
towards the end again a huge thank you
to house of Aurora for being a great
sponsor and everyone should see freaks
when it's eventually playing in their
area yeah thanks so much really thanks
to Collider thank you guys have been
awesome
so far on that note
[Music]